over the weekend did you know this
President Trump came to Los Angeles for
a fundraiser did you know that who went
anybody here go that's fascinating that
one person this crowd into the Trump LA
fundraiser I know he has 15,000 laying
around exactly no people gave him money
to get the hell out of Los Angeles
that's good ticket prices you were right
the ticket prices for Trump's fundraiser
went from fifteen thousand dollars to a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars yes
for fifteen thousand dollars you got
your picture taken with Trump for
$150,000 you didn't get your picture
taken yeah that's what's the story
that's something that really happened he
didn't get my picture taken for it with
him for free yeah
a billion dollars yeah the fundraiser
took place in Beverly Hills and
apparently no celebrities attended no
celebrities in Beverly Hills not the
President of the United States not one
celebrity you can't go to Quiznos in
Beverly Hills without seeing George
Clooney he works there
I don't know have never heard of that
before a Beverly Hills fundraiser not
one celebrity I know not easily they
wander in just because they see the
waiters and I know red carpet also he
wasn't done at the us-mexico border did
you hear this at the us-mexico border
this weekend President Trump said the
country is full yeah
in response Native Americans said why
didn't we think of that sorry 18th
century Englishman but we are full we're
good
oh we didn't realize we'll just sail
back